what do you think of a burger what you
need is a great sauce and I like smoky
barbecue goes hand in glove with a great
burger
start by finely chopping one onion and
three cloves of garlic my smart pan
tablespoon of olive oil onions and
garlic into the pan a nice seasoning
salt and pepper now the secret of a good
barbecue sauce is that really important
camera zation to begin with a nice
tablespoon brown sugar it darkens the
onions but it really starts to sort of
give that nice syrupy body to the source
I'll put a little bit of heat in there
now a nice teaspoon of smoked paprika
that's the important part of working
with spices gotta cook them out
whoa I sort of burn off that walnuts
especially with a smoked paprika it's
exactly where I want it to go onions and
garlic beautifully caramelized cider
vinegar in could you sat down now I've
got a fantastic smoky base to complete
the sauce I'm making my life really easy
and adding pre-made Worcester sauce and
tomato ketchup turn that out for two to
three minutes now depending on how thick
you like the barbecue sauce that term is
how long you cook it out for I don't
want to be too runny but a knowledge
suite they either that's the consistency
we're looking for
[Music]
but we turn on the gas
and such a season now take that out is
the kind of source that I'd like to have
sort of bottled up in the fridge it's
great for sandwiches but goes
brilliantly well with these sliders
homemade smoky barbecue sauce get a
panel of white now start the mix to the
sliders so you might mix a really
interesting flavor and texture I'm gonna
be using unsmoked Bank bacon I travel
all over the world and I spend a lot of
time in the States they know how to make
a great slider text sliders beef sliders
chicken sliders there's almost like a
way of having a burger but on a much
smaller miniature level teaspoon of
olive oil on that bacon to get really
nice and crispy bacon in this just gives
the really nice sort of chunky delicious
makes on texture and pork is perfect for
a slider and tapash lot slots are a lot
sweeter than your normal white onion
five five five and in now that Bacon's
getting really nice and crispy I want a
bit of heat in there a little teaspoon
smoked paprika in there and we see these
fibers in the states and one portion
there's like four or five of them a
little mini one bite us incredible now
take your pork just open up and give
that a really nice evening so important
you can't season a slider after you
cooked it impossible so seasoned it
nicely baked now it's nice and crispy
just take little touch kitchen run and
just drain that off there
pat that nice and dry I want all that
nice sort of Chris penis in there
beautiful mix all that in take a nice
ball and sort of roll it size of a golf
ball get it nice and round first and
then three fingers just Pat that down
don't flap them too thin otherwise be
able to cook and they go sort of dry
because sliders are bite-sized burgers
designed to go in small buns you don't
want to make them too big yes
get a pan nice and hot tablespoon of
olive oil when a slider is literally
that affect about an inch thick we're
going to take two and a half to three
minutes each side in
[Music]
tell them over lovely once you've turned
them tilt the pan and just spoon all
that juice back into them
give my mouth watering up very easy to
dry the pork out so just feeling it now
you think is nice and firm the little
touch of springiness in the center and
happy rhodes add your cheese now still
gets nicely melted I'm using wedges of
smoked cheddar and it has that nice sort
of sorry smoky creaminess to the slider
finely shredded baby gem lettuce just
take those buns make sure they're sliced
nice and evenly take your lettuce quite
generous from the lettuce it's a nice
thin slice of tomato take your burgers
see that cheese
goofy melted the barbecue sauce place
the top on
and that is my version the slider that
is small dynamic but packed full of
flavor I'll take that over Hamburg any
day
[Music]
like that we call this butterfly in the
chicken I want the crispness on the top
the pure on the bottom of the can off
and then it